do you ever wonder why
some actors
come to depend
so much on their craft there are
actors who say that if they
couldn't act they couldn't live and we
might at first scoff
at such a statement like what do you
mean like
you need acting like
why do you need it it's supposed to be
just a just a fun hobby or or something
you love but to need it that
co-dependence but see here's the thing i
think that
we fail to realize that actors
especially
especially gifted actors are privy to
a form of psychotherapy
that
comes to be seen
as
[Music]
comes to be seen comes to be seen as as
non-negotiable in other words like
actors get to work out their stuff on
screen they get to work out their stuff
from a place of safety from a container
absent of self-consciousness they're
basically given permission by the
fellow actors directors by the whole
production by the scaffolding built
around them they are given permission to
act out their inner life right they say
find the truth of that character inside
of you so if this character is angry how
are you truthful under the imaginary
circumstances you're not this character
and you're not angry right because this
is this character who's angry not you
but guess what they're basically giving
you permission to go to a place inside
of you where you know anger right maybe
you're angry at your ex-girlfriend maybe
you're angry at your mother maybe you're
angry at the boss that treated you like
[ __ ] there are parts of you that no pain
that no rejection that no frustration
and that no anger but most of us don't
get the permission we aren't asked much
less paid 20 million dollars to blow our
load all over the stage psycho
emotionally speaking i mean actors are
basically told have a nervous breakdown
when we say action and and what's
amazing is that the constellation built
around them the scaffolding the stage
the director the actors the production
built around them acts as a feather bed
it acts as a kind of inflatable castle
right like when little kids celebrate
birthday parties and you put him in the
inflatable castle all of a sudden he
doesn't have to be careful anymore all
of a sudden he doesn't have to follow
any of the rules inside the inflatable
castle he can do somersaults forwards
and backwards he can bang his head
against the wall it's all good in fact
it's healthy right let them act out
their impulses well actors get to act
out those impulses they get to work
through their inner stuff they get to
work through their inner verse their
trauma they get to like marshall and
chew on their pain their loss their
doubt their fear their their indignities
they work through their [ __ ] and we pay
to watch and what a gift you know you
know we say like wow like they're so
lucky well yeah but they're not just
lucky for what we pay them they're lucky
because they get permission they get to
do on stage what we cannot do ourselves
and so in turn they become archetypes
through which we through kind of
aesthetic distance they act they they
play a role for us vicariously right
because everybody can't work out through
their [ __ ] because our society is not
constructed so everybody can just act
out their inner life it would lead to to
the lord of the flies it would lead to
perhaps the most destructive tendencies
emerging and who knows we all contain
monsters but the actor do it on stage
and do it when we say action and
archetypalize for all of us a vision of
the full spectrum of human emotion and
work through your [ __ ] because what we
see on screen is a reflection of our own
inner verse right cinema is
consciousness externalized cinema shows
us the mind of a character how do you
show the mind if the mind is inside the
mind doesn't get acted out but the actor
he gets to act out the mind with all of
its existential wrestling he gets to
live out his inner verse and he gets to
have that embodied therapy of living out
his inner life inside of his
psychological stage and inflatable
castle and wow when they come out of
those experiences they are healed and
they are often made
cleansed they are they're cleansed it's
a baptism you say action and the actor
can go there and he can be baptized by
grace he can find redemption in
absolution he can work out his [ __ ] so
the question then becomes do we settle
for just
the aesthetic distance
of going to the theater right or the
opera or the movies and watching someone
else act out their inner life and
beautifully performed craftsmanship or
do we also find places and spaces where
the everyman can work through his own
[ __ ] should we all join an improv acting
class should we all go to a primal
scream therapy class should we all just
go to a place where you know as part of
like our own psychological education we
are regularly provided with an
intervention that says okay open up
unleash free the brave reckless god that
lives inside of you even if you smash
all the walls and leave nothing in your
wake it's okay act it out live it out
and i think what that can do is it can
expunge us of this kind of like
neuroticism and it can free us and and
allow us to become more integrated more
holistic beings by having at least
fully um accepted all sides of ourselves
not just our our highest and lofty and
beautiful aspirations but our pain and
our loss and our grief and our shame and
the you know the indignities of the
human condition
and and and from this place we can move
past anxiety and self-doubt and
illumination and we can we can clean the
stuff inside of us and i think if actors
get to do it and i love them for it all
of us should get to do it whether it's
in a festival or psychedelic scream
therapy or a dance hall we need to just
like put this messaging in culture and
we need to craft spaces where they can
just work out their stuff you know it's
like it's like give them a place to run
you know like give us a place to like
yeah to to misbehave and to emotionally
act out again to act out our interverse
and work through our darkness like we
need to do that otherwise like we're
living a lie and it's only a matter of
time before that kind of smush snack
that that that grief and pain and loss
and doubt that comes crashing like a
freight train and ruins all our lives
like i think we need the redemptive
power of art which is another way of
saying safe spaces to work out our stuff
without hurting others and without
hurting ourselves that's what we need
that's what actors have that's what
[Music]